so ben you can tell us what are you
doing right now i'm gonna go have coffee
with my good friend jordan peterson
[Applause]
jordan's great our conversations are
always really fun the thing is that no
matter where the conversation starts and
usually it will start at kind of this
level like the top kind of surface level
we'll end up way down at the bottom of
the iceberg by the time we finish the
conversation that's the fun of talking
with them last night we actually went
out to a country western bar
and i will say that must have been a
weird experience for all the people who
just walked into a random
bar on broadway and all of a sudden
jordan peterson and i were sitting there
that was a strange experience it's also
really funny because yeah
in my down time i tend to dress a little
bit more casually than i do on the show
and jordan
i think wears his three-piece suit to
bed maybe so when we were at the at the
bar last night jordan was wearing a nice
suit he's got a sweater vest on he's got
a tie on like all the way up
it's pretty rare that we kind of run up
directly against one another where he
says something and i really dramatically
oppose what he's saying um but it's
pretty frequent that he'll come at
something from an oblique angle that i
hadn't thought about and then i'll come
at it from a different angle that he
hasn't thought about and that's that's
really what makes the conversation fun
it's sort of like conversational tennis
except we're really not trying to score
points against one another it really is
just sort of
sort of batting it around becoming
you know clearer on what we're talking
about every step of the way it's our
conversations
they tend to be like peeling an onion
and they just sort of get deeper deeper
into the onion as the conversation goes
on because both jordan and i have made
our bones a little bit in the
confrontational space
i think we both get a kick out of the
fact that
personality wise neither one of us
actually is particularly confrontational
uh which is you know a thing that i
think most people don't perceive about
either of us and when you look me up on
youtube the first thing you're going to
get is a ben shapiro destroys video and
when you look jordan up you're gonna get
jordan uh you know being very
impassioned about
the about fundamental truths but when
you actually interact with either one of
us on a personal level we're actually
relatively soft-spoken like we can get
aggressive when we push too far but
there's some real personality
similarities i think we've never had a
five minute conversation every
conversation jordan and i have is a 45
minute to an hour conversation minimum
because we get into deep territory real
quickly because it's just the stuff we
enjoy talking about so it's a
it's fun it's a real meaning of mind
[Music]